all right we are live Ian Crossland
thank you so much for coming on today
how are you I'm great man thanks for
having me I know a lot of people already
know who you are will you introduce
yourself to those who are new to your
presence yeah the most likely place
you've seen me is on timcast IRL as one
of the co-hosts um and also I've been
I've been doing internet video since
2006 I I co-founded minds.com with Bill
opman and I I'm a musician and an actor
in addition to a lot of that stuff it's
it's been a wild Jimmy yeah um I have
you know I've watched a million episodes
of timcast and I have to say you've
always been my favorite because you're
into the whole spiritual realm you're
into all the various you know
conspiracies and everything else and you
have probably the most open mind like
you're one thing I love about you is how
inquisitive you are and every time I'd
see an episode I'm like I need to talk
to Ian Crossland and so when he finally
got to link up in person a few months
ago uh you know over in Virginia to be
on timcast sure enough I knew it you and
I hit it off right off the bat I think
the if the audience wants it we should
do like a show like a fullon like skull
scul and Moulder like full on dude
because you got the data I got these
wild
ideas both have a little bit of both
yeah and and and we were talking about
before like we need to travel to some
places there are some places you still
haven't been to Egypt we gotta get and
you were I haven't talked to you about
your Balck experience oh dude I haven't
honed in what was it
like it exceeded my expectations which
were already High I went to Balck
Lebanon back in September and in my mind
going there I was under the impression
that if there was one site on Earth that
was evidence of a lost ancient Advanced
civilization it's bulbeck now the great
pyramid Giza in my mind is functional
and is is as sophisticated as it gets
but I'm from this from the standpoint of
the fact that there are Stones there
particularly three stones called the
trilon stones that are over 900 tons a
piece that that Were Somehow moved a
mile and then lifted and stacked
perfectly 30 feet off the ground you
have to see it and so when I was there I
wanted to know firsthand what my
eyeballs see to to just kind of verify
in my own mind to be like is this as
spectacular and and true evidence of of
something advanc happening in in the
ancient past and it confirmed it and
exceeded it it's some I'm telling you
and I say this a million times that like
when you see something you see photos
you're like oh wow look how big that
stone is but then when you go there and
you see it with your own eyeballs I knew
I was in the presence of greatness
um is it the kind of thing where just
like just airships alone could have made
it happen like if they just had enough
balloon power and and ropes and just Flo
this this is what's Wild like I'm open
to that idea and we should talk about
that but as far as like let me just say
back before that um are you familiar
with that that six engine transport jet
that was destroyed in Ukraine it's the
Antonov 227 I believe that it's the most
sophisticated highest capacity payload
plane in the world or was before it got
blown up at the during the invasion of
Ukraine um but this those stones exceed
the max capability of even that because
we're talking over two million pounds um
so a piece so I don't know man like you
brought up like into anyone listening
like when you're talking about like
airships balloons and stuff it kind of
ties into the movie Dune have you seen
that yet not the movie I read the book
oh right on I haven't read it all right
so you should watch the new movie and
everyone watching it dude it's it's I
think it's a masterpiece um but yeah so
I'm open-minded to all that what what I
will say is this when it comes to
actually these stones are flush they're
perfectly lined up and it's one thing to
like move and drag things because like
the mainstream Skeptics will say oh well
they used elephants they used you know
animals and they dragged them and they
used pulley they did this and that and
I'm like once those Limestone blocks get
on top of each other limestone's rough
and the amount of energy you would have
to have it's one thing to pull two
million pounds it's another thing to put
two million pounds into the Earth and
continue to pull it where you have all
this resistance that multitudes the the
the amount of energy you'd have to to
make so it almost looks like they were
just to answer your question it does
look like as if they were just placed
down as opposed to dragged on because
that's what the mainstream people say
it's like oh they were draged on and
stuff and I'm like these things are
perfect so I I don't know ever since I
heard about the V which is this ancient
Hindu flying Palace and it's like oh did
the king fly around on like a giant
platform with like 700,000 hot air
balloons attached to it to have like a
little city on this and I mean the
images of the the V are like a it's like
a tri it's like a a pyramid kind of a
flying pyramid but I pictured more of a
platform with hot air balloons I don't
know man hot airall is not that
complicated of a technology so I could
kind of imagine that because we've had
those since the 1800s it's kind of
primitive it's it's actually you know it
could be done in the ancient past um I
will say real quick to anyone listening
uh if you're interested in asking us a
question I'll be monitoring the chat is
the best my ability the super chats
stand out for sure so if you have any
questions for me and Ian as we get going
feel free to do that um so real quick so
you're everyone is aware you're in a
hotel room in Iowa and we did this short
notice it's a negative three degrees I
think it's it's the first time I've been
in negative temperature weather in what
is it negative negative six outside
that's without the wind I think yeah
it's only negative six Fahrenheit uh
I've been barricaded Inside the Hotel
all day I think I'm gonna go out and get
dinner in a couple few hours right on
Tim we were just chatting I'm grab a tea
while I'm listening yeah right on so we
were just chatting before we went live
so Ian is in a position because of you
know being on timcast you're meeting all
kinds of amazing people and we were just
talking about vivec uh because you've
met him personally um and you're
interacting with some very interesting
people um I don't know if we have to we
don't have to get into the politics
right off the bat um oh by the way we
just got a nice Super Chat here 50 bucks
from Life Rotel thank you very much very
generous um but I don't know we don't
have to get into the politics right off
the bat we could back burner that a
little bit because I know a lot of
people here I marketed this as we're
going to discuss conspiracies and
ancient Mysteries um what are your
thoughts is this dive into some
conspiracies like what do you think
what's standing out to you right now we
were just talking about immigration and
everything else like what's what's on
your radar right now aliens it's going
to be an alien conspiracy there's going
to be they're going to use talking
plasma or similar technology where they
take like lasers from base stations or
from orbital you know satellites or
whatever but they triangulate or biang I
think you need I don't know how many
lasers you need to to coordinate to to
make this happen but you you centralize
these lasers into a position and they
all hit this one spot and create a a
ball of plasma and it's just there
floating where the lasers are connecting
and then you can move that around that
intersection and it looks like on a
radar it looks like a craft they're like
how does it move no craft can move like
that it's because it's plasma they're
moving it around and if you have enough
lasers you could make like moving and
you can teleport sound through this
stuff it's called talking plasma you go
to Military times.com and check it out
Military times talking plasma and um I
would imagine some sort of alien SC but
the thing is if we talk about it enough
then it won't happen so but that's what
I think would be like the the next
obvious one also maybe another
virus yeah um real quick so as far as
this alien stuff do you think that
they're going to do like a fake Alien
Invasion do you think that it's our
technology and that they're they the
powers that be are going to manipulate
us through and to pretend that this is
hey these are aliens screwing with us
but it's really us like what do you or
or is it being from other planets that
are here I think it's all Earth all
terrestrial technology human technology
I think they r Tesla's lab and took
learned how to get like long range
electric electricity they probably have
Fusion generators on little drones that
they fly around so there's talking
plasma and then there's
drones have have you ever seen um oh
you're you're breaking up a little bit
you kind of froze up everyone he's on
the hotel Wi-Fi so if he goes in and out
um I'll just keep going but I know you
guys can hear me so Ian if you can hear
me just know that you're still
frozen I I had a feeling this would
happen thanks so I'm in a hotel and I'm
getting like five megabytes down and
about three megabytes up but that's
sometimes cutting out intermittently so
that might happen four or five more
times in the show but because Jimmy has
such high Charisma I think it's gonna be
fine I'm I'm send Good Vibes Into The
Ether here yeah I'll always come back it
might just take like 10 20 seconds yeah
um that it's both I don't know where
I okay I'm back again let's that was fun
it's all right just keep going you cut
out I'll just keep going yeah okay cool
I think so it's basically basically I
don't know where I cut out but that it's
drones uh like long range Tesla either
electricity that they're beaming to
these craft or they have Fusion
generators on board and they're flying
drones around and they're flying they're
moving talking plasma around like a
laser pointer have you seen one of these
orbs in person with your own eyes
negative so neither of I know of I will
say um Brian who works with you guys um
that does all the logistics of moving
people around with the show he said he
seen some wild stuff um I will say drone
operator yeah he's a really I love Brian
I hope he's listening um I will say my
brother and his wife who are down toe
people they're not storytellers I trust
them and they were staying at an Airbnb
in northern Arizona up on the Mogan Rim
in Pine Arizona and this was just a few
years ago and they were on the back
patio kind of overlooking the Horizon in
at dusk and all of a sudden they see
there was this orange glowing orb going
horizontally across the sky and all and
they're like what is that it's not a it
was L glowing just exactly like you hear
described these glowing orbs and then
all of a sudden went to the to outer
space like that and they were just jaw
dropped they like what is that what
happened like this is not our technology
and when you hear so although I and you
have not seen this ourselves when you
have people that you know when you trust
that I've seen something like this that
you know it's like what's going on you
know what what are these things and
what's Wild is that that describes the
same exact thing that Ronald Reagan back
when he was running for president had
seen um back when he was governor maybe
um he had describe the same thing I
don't know if you know that story but
this is the same story other people have
described this is I I did cut out while
you were telling that story uh special
shout out to the Hyatt um where I'm I'm
staying and uh all the the awesome
public Wi-Fi that they have accessible
do they not have like a $10 a day option
for faster stuff oh no and I wish they
did no they have just a general open wi
so maybe a bunch of people like log in
and um talk about so you're saying that
what I heard was that this this drone
they saw the the light go across the
Horizon and then the red light like shot
up into the atmosphere and what did you
say about re what was Reagan working on
it so Reagan described the same thing
this is documented back when he was
governor I think he was running for
president at the time he was in a a a
government jet and the pilots they all
witnessed it and they're like what is
that there was some sort of glowing orb
and then he describes it as shooting up
to the heavens as he described it
instantaneously and this is back in the
early 80s I think of that as talking
plasma is like a laser show basically
they're they're they're aiming lasers at
a point and then moving a plasma ball
and then just moving the point like flip
you take a laser pointer on the wall and
just turn it up really quick then what
is it is it like a device for
observation or is it just like what is
it why like what's the point um well I
know they can teleport sound through it
I think they can make it look like
images too they can teleport imagery
through it to be honest I don't know um
it it also maybe like craft maybe like a
distortion technique uh radar Distortion
technique but uh there's also something
called fairy lights that's a different I
think that's a different technology that
you can actually make make it look like
um almost that you can touch like if you
get close to it there'll start to feel
like there's something there if you're
pressing against it because there's so
much repulsive uh uh feeling but I don't
know a lot too much about fyes I've only
read a little bit about talking plasma
when you mentioned fairy lights it
reminds me the same exact thing that I
just described involving an orb so
Christopher Columbus who did not
discover anything uh when he was on his
journey across the Atlantic have you
heard about this he described that there
was a Red Orb that followed them for a
period of time have you heard this no
okay look into it it's Dr dou umented
I'm not this is not from Bob's website
like this is literal historical
information that's in the archives you
can read it's in his log journal for the
boat they describe a Red Orb following
them I don't remember for how long but
for a period of time what the what it
what well see as as we have talking
plasma from Earth you can like
triangulate lasers from from Earth I
don't see why like an alien civilization
couldn't do it from their planet and
like point the laser at Earth you just
have to have a strong enough laser but
if you point it at Earth and then move
it around but that takes time for light
to travel and then there is quantum
entanglement so like there are other
methods of teleportation than than light
travel but to jump to jump to aliens is
like just such a leap I my mind isn't
capable of allowing me to I'm too
skeptical I gotcha um I would need some
sort of
evidence I you know the thing is is that
when people ask me what I think about
this this is this is how Wild of an idea
I have is that I think we are the aliens
and I don't mean that from the
standpoint that if someone is on another
intelligent being on another planet if
they knew life exists on Earth they
would think of us as aliens I think
we're hybrids I think that the human
species is so bizarre that it would make
sense that if you look at these
religious texts that describe the
Nephilim coming and uh breeding with the
women on earth like it would almost
makes sense that we're hybrids because
I'm like there's some real holes in the
arguments of evolution involving the
human species like particularly the
cranial cavity how much it shrank over a
period of time that that contradicts
what we think we know about about
Evolution and I'm like we don't
assimilate with our environment at all
like if you look at all the animals and
all the insects like everything is like
this ecosystem of like nothing leaves a
trace it all like you know death and
rebirth everything's feeding off each
other and like if you look at a city
from outer space tell me it does not
look like a cancer
spot we're like a cancer on the I'm like
are we really from here and I you know
so I'm like when people want to know
what I think I'm like we're probably we
are the aliens and the and our overlords
are probably living inside the Earth or
under the ocean right now and and there
are the orbs oh that's there someone was
just saying that the center of the earth
is actually plasma it's a plasma field
like the sun it's like a mini Sun so
that people could have been living in
the hollow Earth like the Earth isn't
necessarily all thick and like solid
there probably Gap I mean there are gaps
and caverns within it that like they
that might have been their Sun for some
one for some ancient under As Above So
Below and it looks like you're cutting
out so um the thing is is that to anyone
that's followed my work and I talk about
the Adam and Eve story which let me give
a quick shout out to Ben from suspicious
observers him and I are going to be
going we were both invited to we're I
got you back you broke up a little bit
but I was going I was just mentioning
about the Adam and Eve story describes
the interior of the earth as being a
plasma a sun what's that I can jump
my my local Wi-Fi let me try this yeah
do that do that um and I'll I'll keep
going um but I was just mentioning how
uh Ben Davidson of suspicious observers
and myself have just been invited to
come back on to uh the Tim uh show uh
culture wars you'll be on uh should be
next week I'm waiting on Flight
confirmation so I'm I'm not gonna
announce any Hard dates on that because
you know things change all the time in
this world um but I was just mentioning
I see I got you back you were breaking
up a little bit but I was just
mentioning how and I
oh Ben Davis is coming too yeah yeah so
I I got the invite from Lisa I'm waiting
to get Flight confirmation and uh and so
he got the invite as well she's like we
usually people on in pairs and uh and
and to anyone listening we're gonna be
talking about climate change we're g be
talking about the historical data that
contradicts The Narrative of what's
being presented right now um but anyway
so that's what made me think of it is
that the abane story which I learned
from Ben Davidson that's what made me
think of him uh describes that the in
Earth is a
sun that's just what the it makes sense
I mean we have a magnetic field I always
wondered how like just molten iron would
produce a magnetic field and I guess if
it's moving fast enough it is magnetic
and could sort of make a charge but like
it's got it always kind of was just like
okay I accepted it because that was what
I was taught but yeah it makes a lot
more sense that it's so hot that it's
become plasma they don't know what
they're talking about and I I'd like to
point out like the Earth's crust is like
30 miles deep and the the deepest we've
ever drilled into the crust is like
seven miles it was done in Russia like a
couple decades ago um so like we really
don't know we know that there's
something happening in the earth that
there's this constant movement and the
theory of like our magnetic field is
that there's this clump of iron just
moving around that's molten but I'm like
we're essentially floating on something
there's something going on in the earth
that we don't fully understand I can
wrap my head around that it's molten
because like volcanoes and such but
inner earth is a whole Wild Thing and
yes it is totally possible that there
are beings living in there and that
sounds like some conspiracy nonsense to
some people but there's a whole there's
hundreds of miles thousands of miles
before you get to the center of the
earth and hundreds of miles in between
that could feasibly be inhabited I mean
they they find these caves I watch
enough documentaries you see that
there's these caves deep in the earth
that have all kinds of animal life
living in them like roaches and various
bizarre you know insects so it doesn't
even have to be carbon based life either
sulfur based life at the bottom of the
ocean that's like that lives off of
sulfur Vents and like we're carbon based
life but that doesn't mean it so it
could be other you know silicon Bas I
don't know sulfur based life in the
planet for sure I I learned about plasma
like in high school and I had a science
teacher that told me there were only
three states of matter in high school I
was told that and I'm like there are
four states of matter plasma she's like
no there's there's I think that was I
think that was her that told me that I
remember being told by a teacher that
there were only three after I'd read
that there were four so like this plasma
thing's kind of relatively newly
understood in the last hundred years or
right it's it's I call it future science
like there are things that exist that
we're not we don't scientifically
understand today but like x amount of
years from now will be Calon knowledge
and and and then look back at us and be
like look at these primitive losers from
100 years ago that didn't understand
plasma you know so so I think that we
are and by the way I change networks I'm
on my personal
Wi-Fi network so hopefully it's better
let me know if it it sus it's more crisp
people can leave a comment um it looks
great you look handsome crisp and clear
um so I think that we are hom I think
we're from Earth that we evolve from the
Apes slowly over time by consuming
mushrooms and inbreeding that we went
off into these small tribes and just
each other and then became human
over and over and over so it's like
severely inbred species um wiped out the
ne but but that I also think we're
hyperdimensional and that we have access
to like magnetic fluence and that we can
alter like there's no reason that we
couldn't bring orbs onto the into into
witness like that our our Consciousness
something is more in tune with like the
magnetic fields of Earth and the Sun and
the galactic sphere that that we're that
we are likely bending light and
causing maybe even plasma because the
way plasma moves is very interesting it
doesn't move like a cloud in the Wind
doesn't just blow around it like it
moves like a sentient like plasma fields
are like being innervated or something
by external forces probably
photons and uh I wonder how how attuned
our Consciousness is to like controlling
that or manipulating it real quick
someone just left a comment are you guys
Masons no I well let me not speak for
you are you a free mason Ian I'm not I
would like to be though no no it's
devilry
I no secrets are not cool uh and that's
what that operates on secret societies
uh I'm sure there's plenty wonderful
Masons out there but uh no I am not a
Freemason and but I'm of the policy that
because I know some high level
Freemasons and they said that there's
certain knowledge that they know about
that they can't share with the public or
people that aren't highle high level
Masons and I'm like full stop no this is
2024 and secrets are not cool and I
think that to withhold information
historical or whatever from the masses
is at this point Harris say I don't like
it what if what if we became Masons and
then convinced them or at least we
became the most popular and got elevated
to the top and then convince the whole
masonry to reveal right hold on we got a
comment from an Emily she said um no
Emily Howard nope Freemasonry is good
but what you think about Freemasonry is
fake and not really what it is hey Emily
and I say this with respect I'm just
playing devil's advocate here so I'm not
like Sharp Shooting you but you are a
female and you are not allowed in
Freemasonry that is is a male only Club
except for in France uh they changed
that up there um and so I'm just
pointing that out I'm like all right so
if we want to talk about genders and
this other stuff it's like well hey you
as a lady unless your husband's a
Freemason and he's sharing all the good
stuff with you uh you know late at night
you got to let us know some
secrets I'm just having what is like is
it the cabala that the the Mason I I
wish I mean I know you're not a mason so
asking you is kind of like just throwing
darts into the dark I I don't know but
what's the good stuff um I believe so
the core Foundation of Freemasonry from
what I understand is about preserving
important knowledge that was once
considered illegal in other places in
Europe uh I could be wrong I'm not the
best person to speak on this but it's
about preserving important sacred
knowledge and and passing it down
because at one point in time it would
have got you killed
so I I i' no doubt that most Freemasons
are good people I if there was any
conspiracy there at such a high level
above what what these normal Freemasons
would think um there's rumors that
Freemasons were involved in um planning
the French Revolution and other things
so like it does get a little bit uh
interesting but I'm not the person to
speak about and I don't want to I don't
need to tarnish Masons because there's
other Freemasons in this in the field
that I'm in and I don't want this to
sound like it's directed at them because
it's not yeah they used to be it was
secret society like you wouldn't even
tell people that you were a Mason I
believe back in the day they had like
secret handshake and stuff but now
people are very open about oh
interesting yeah well if there's I know
some Masons I I I'm down to join the
cult but like I'm also gonna tell the
secrets eventually so know that if
you're letting me in and needs to
infiltrate they're not gonna let me in
because I blasted Freemasons on Twitter
so I'm out of the I'm not welcome in
that club I can assure you of that I
guess the thing about secrecy I was
talking to Vi about this a couple nights
ago on IRL is like it was like the last
thing that we said before we closed the
show is like sometimes you have to lie
for the betterment of people and I was
like he was everyone was like what but
I'm like well like the Manhattan Project
we were building the nuclear bomb and
first of all we didn't tell anyone about
it that's not necessarily A Lie that's
just being discreet but if someone were
to ask like the scientists are you
building an atom bomb they go no they
would lie to your face they would if is
there a Manhattan Project no there's not
like and that's a righteous lie because
if you like yes there is but I can't
tell you about it then all of a sudden
the Nazis are like oh there is well
let's look for this thing that's called
The Manhattan Project and you're like no
you got to lie about it like to everyone
right and that's okay so I don't know I
I'm getting a lot of comments here I
just got a super chat from Steve mckel
said ask R Carlson he's am Mason yes so
Randle Carlson is a high level Freemason
and I want to make it clear that I do
not think that Randle carlsson is some
Insidious Freemason at all so that's why
I was careful to say it's like you know
I don't want people think this directed
him I have no doubt that he's he's one
of the good guys so just to be clear on
that um my conspiracy brain is thinking
like oh there could be people above him
that are deceiving everyone but I don't
know that and it's all you know who
knows so enough about them for a minute
um by the way so real quick I want to
get on to the topic of ancients a lot of
people saw these articles that came out
in the last two days talking about this
huge civilization that was found
underneath the Amazon uh rainforest in
Ecuador 6,000 homes entire neighborhoods
Farms roads previously totally unknown
go back 2500 to 3,000 years ago more
than a thousand years prior to what was
pre L known just discovered through liar
mapping which is lasers that are pinged
from the air in this in space that over
millions of times the unidentify
structures underneath all the foliage
that you can't see you can't even see it
if you're walking over it like you're
literally Walking On Homes and roads but
there are so many feet below all the you
know the leaves and foliage and
everything that's fallen down and um
yeah I uh this discovery is huge because
it once again vindicates Graham Hancock
and you and I were talking about about
this offline um five years ago almost he
was on Joe Rogan getting ready to
announce his new book America before
where he was actively advocating for lar
mapping the entire region of the Amazon
because there had been little
discoveries here and there in that
region that identifi that okay there's
something we are constantly finding
things underneath the ground of the
Amazon and now it's been proven right so
I just want to give a quick shout out to
Graham Hancock for being right for the h
hundredth time and meanwhile mainstream
archaeology had slowed down that process
by years because they were like saying
that it was a waste of time to even go
look like I can't even believe this
people that are interested this go look
on Twitter go look on X and you can see
like people are trying to like prevent
giving him credit it's like anyway so I
just want to give some uh homage to him
because he was right once again I
consider yeah Graham is like the
preeminent archaeologist on Earth I
don't even know if he's you could
consider him he considers himself a
writer and a researcher but I mean I
he's done yeah but I I will say I
consider him an archaeologist just
because of the way he's uncovered and in
inspired people and incited people to
uncover ancient history like and I don't
know if you need to actually uncover
like hard evidence to become an
archaeologist if it's actually about the
study of the the physical or if it's
more about just learning about ancient
culture that's archaeology maybe that's
just more of a
historian uh thanks thanks to gr BR yeah
I was gonna say as far as being
archaeologist you have to in their in
their Realm you got to go get a degree
and you're not even considered anything
this as an advanced degree like a
Masters or a PhD in the field and and I
think all that's wonderful and I have no
doubt I can learn many things through
mainstream archaeology but the reality
is that it's become dogmatic and there
are so let's just be clear what they
teach about if you go get a a degree in
in archaeology they are not going to
teach you that there was any advanced
ancient civilization that predates the
samans the Sam they will tell you that
the pyramids were tombs they would not
have included anything about A Lost
Civilization underneath the soil of the
Amazon rainforest so the point is that
alternative ancient history which I call
myself and and and for Graham Hancock he
just calls himself a journalist he's
reporting what's being found that's not
being shared from the other side and and
that's really what it comes down to so
it's like you know you don't have to be
an archaeologist to to learn to read
about every single thing that's known
about from ancient history you know we
got we got the
today is I know I love like in in the in
the Amazon is it like I've heard that
they they the ancient civilizations that
lived there are the ones that fertiliz
the soil such that it could become a
rainforest dude this is so I learned
that from him that is a fact that that
super dark black soil that is the most
nutrient efficient soil on Earth that
created a rainforest I couldn't believe
it so that was man-made they don't know
how or why or what but the Amazon
rainforest is by definition
artificial that soil and there's un an
unbelievable unfathomable amount of it
was geoengineered it's it's it's
human-made I couldn't believe it when I
learned that but people who don't
believe me look it look into it as the
saying goes yeah so it's like what do
they figure out how far back do you
think humans were
cultivating
well all right so here's what we do know
according to the textbooks now gockley
teepe in Turkey dates back to 11,600
years ago uh the Skeptics will say that
it was built by hunters and gatherers um
anyone that's not familiar with gobec
teepe it is the earliest human
settlement ever found it's sophisticated
200 pillars 90% of it of which is still
buried under the ground 20 uh 20 foot
tall 20 ton pillars and it seems to be
um cosmically oriented it looks like a
compass but it's not a compass that's
not what I'm saying but it's circular
nature and there's many uh mounds of it
and um so to answer your question we
know now that 11,600 years ago but that
just to put this in perspective gockley
teepe predates Stonehedge by
7,000 years so before it was the
samarians in Mesopotamia you know uh the
cradle of civilization that was like the
early stuff you know 6,000 years ago now
we have gockley
tape I'm inclined to think that it's
only a matter of time before we find
something significantly older that
predates the Ice Age so that's what I'm
wondering because that gockley Tey as
far as I can tell is after the Comets
struck North America or there and there
was a pole shift or whatever happened
that causes global cataclysm multiple
Global cataclysms and floods the the his
the people that survived Atlantis a
ancient Greeks if that was if the
ancient Athenians were real they say
they were but might be bullshitting like
that might be history historic
propaganda it could have just been
Atlanta dominated but they fled there
and they rebuilt in gockley tee that was
like a where they they they got some of
the knowledge there like architecture
some architecture knowledge and some
like uh irrigation knowledge and they
were able to kind of reboot but if you
had to guess how do you think it goes
back like 30,000 years is there any
evidence before that yet yeah so this is
what's Wild is that there is a Kings
list from the samarians predates that
but in Egypt uh there's a there's a
couple there's two different pieces of
evidence that show that they had a
lineage of the Pharaohs that date back
more than 30,000 years mainstream says
well that's not possible we have no
evidence of that not true but that's
what the Egyption said and to anyone
that's not familiar that the height of
the last ice age was 23,000 years ago
and the Ice Age would have wiped out
freaking everything we're talking about
two miles of ice covering continents and
like we all see what happens like
glaciers carve entire valleys that you
could have had a metropolitan area
underneath that ice and would have
grinded it to obliv Oblivion and taken
all the land underneath with it and it'd
be no trace of it sounds far-fetched to
some people but like it's certainly
possible um how does that happen because
when I try and picture ice moving it
it's like an ice would it have to be
like some jerking mechanism that would
like Push It Forward really far really
fast and then it would stop for like a
100 years and then like something would
happen and it would jut forward again or
is it constantly creeping forward yeah
they they describe it as moving like a
slow moving River so like just gravity
it's just like all that ice won't just
stay put it will slowly just move and
over time that's what's grinding Out The
Valleys like you know Northern Canada
and through the United States um you
could see all these some of the most
beautiful landscapes that are now
covered in pine trees uh were you know
in all these massive valleys that was
all carved by glaciers and Glaciers were
were created
by however many years of snow snowing it
it the snow goes down it creates layers
it freezes through being super cold and
it becomes just essentially packed ice
and packed ice is a wickedly powerful
destructive force a quick thank you
lethal trip oh I didn't know if I
clicked this it puts it on the screen
did that put it on all our screen
yeah I oh that's cool I just learned
something new hey thank you lethal trip
I I wish I could go back and find the
other uh people that had done that and
put on the screen my bad now I just can
there's actually a a tab that uh for
Super Chat specifically I think in the
upper right next to the chat tab it's
real easy okay um how you were saying
water is destructive water is actually I
think the best drill known to man they
use water drills you can carve diamonds
with water as far as I know and um in
every water molecule they say it's H2O
that it's two hydrogen's and one oxygen
I've heard that it's just one
hydrogen rapidly teleporting like moving
away and another one's coming in so fast
to replace it but it looks like there's
two at all times even though it's
actually just one whipping around the
oxygen yeah I don't know that's above me
I don't know um it could be but
yeah but when you think about like if
you want to go down the rabbit hole of
like atams how like none of them are
touching because that's what we're
describing is like these molecules of
atoms that are connected so it's like it
is by definition means that it's an
illusion water is an illusion our entire
existence is illusion because no atoms
touch each other they're separated by
vast distances in respect to their size
and they're held together by a
mysterious electrical force because we
don't know what keeps them going as they
do so like by definition everything
we're seeing on a molecular level is by
definition illusion which to me screams
intelligent design I call it I've been
called it an apparation instead of an
illusion only because it it it's
appearing but it it does it's not fake
like when I think of Illusion I think of
it as fake because like pain is real I
mean it may be pain is an illusion but
when I scream out ah it's like it's not
is that also I mean maybe that's also an
illusion but I've just been lately
calling it an apparation because I think
of it as when we think like we're moving
through space we see this
three-dimensional momentum but really
what's happening is we're appearing in
place because these atoms are turning
and then we're just appearing in a new
position like if we're in a a
three-dimensional super position we're
just appearing at any given spot in the
super position at light speed so we're
constantly appearing in a new position
oh so two things one you made me think
of the movie Inception and because I
think about dreams and I just see Emily
Howard who was talk about earlier she
just said it's a dream uh have you seen
Inception Ian yeah but I fell asleep I
think I tried to watch it twice once was
it many years ago or more yeah it was
like in 2009 okay when it came out I
wasn't interested and I didn't
understand the hype then I watched it
like six seven years later just a few
years ago from now um and I watched it I
had like did it edible and I was like oh
my God I get it now and I was just
talking to my girlfriend like we need to
watch this because she had saw where it
first came out and wasn't interested and
I'm like I know so I think you should
read that to your list because now where
you are with all your thoughts and iies
and like spirituality and and
questioning the
Universe I think that it might resonate
a lot differently now I because I I was
just talking last night I'm like we need
to watch this we need to watch it I was
thinking about maybe watching it tonight
you know in the movie you've seen it but
you've seen it so you know in the movie
when like reality starts to rupture
almost like it starts to vibrate and
tear itself apart that's like I don't
know if you've ever Lucid dreamed but if
you're in a lucid dream and then that
you start to wake up from it slowly you
if if it doesn't happen too quick you
see it starts to vibrate and rupture the
entire it's just like Inception just
like that movie all right so I have
lucid Dreamed a few times but I was
gonna say when you describe that when I
I've done two DMT trips and I don't
you've done DMT corre oh no you did
puffed on it I've only sipped I only
sipped iwasa and puffed on DMT I'm about
to go down the rabbit hole so I I did
two Puffs of DMT two separate times I
couldn't make it to the third puff I did
this totally alone I made it myself um
this a few years ago in Boise Ido I was
living alone I was looking for answers
in my life and they all if you research
this they say you got to do three Puffs
three Puffs is what gets you blasted off
but what I can say is that from the two
Puffs that I did I experienced a few
things one which was I heard the pop and
this loud pinging sound inside my head
it wasn't like ttis this was a diff it's
like there's a noise sounds crazy but
that's how I describe it but what Then I
then saw is that so I did this laying in
my bed like sitting up had the pillows
you know just sitting up at the
baseboard and the I swear to God the
room was going w w w w w
w just vibrating and then then I move
then it stopped vibrating like that and
then I started seeing geometric patterns
just as what everyone else is described
but what I saw and I don't need to get
into right now but I saw a goddamn
pyramid on God this is what I saw I saw
a feminine being in fact hold on one
second while I tell this story I'll
finish the story but I just realized I
have to do my little ad reads I can't
forget to do this um so let me read
these off real quick only take a minute
and then I will go straight over and to
finish that story um so half a second
here the first one here uh Ian if you'll
bear with me is Brick House uh
nutritions Field of Greens uh better
nutrition is a key to Health and
Longevity and a healthy diet could even
help you avoid health risk that run in
your family fer greens is my healthy
super fruit and vegetable habit is the
only fruit and vegetable product that is
literally promises Better Health at your
next checkup your doctor will notice
your improved health or your money back
do your vitamins or green drinks promise
Better Health no each superf fruit and
vegetable is in Field of Greens was
Doctor selected for a specific health
benefit some support your health or
excuse me your heart lungs and kidneys
others support metabolism and healthy
energy and weight loss look if resolved
to get a better health in 2024 it starts
with Field of Greens look or excuse me I
got 15% off your first order and free
Rush shipping visit Fielder greens.com
and use promo code bright Insight that's
promo code bright Insight Fielder
greens.com I highly recommend I've tried
this stuff myself they sent it to me and
it actually was really tasty um so real
quick let me just read the next sponsor
bear with me and guys just so you know
like these companies I vetted them
they're actually legit they treated me
good and and the more importantly are
americanmade in support freedom of
speech and it turns out like it's
organic stuff it's it's it's healthy and
so I'm like okay this stuff is legit so
I'll you know I'll go ahead and support
them they're supporting me but they are
a sponsor so real
quick I put it in my smoothies it's so
good I'm gonna go to it is actually good
I couldn't believe it it's so good dude
yeah I feel so good it's got that
magnesium in it yes and magnesium has
all kinds of benefits um so real quick
let me just present this one and you
guys bear with me and give back to my
DMT story okay here we go uh so this
next one is bio optimizers January is
here can you believe it how are you
doing with your New Year's resolutions
mine was pretty easy to focus on my
well-being which I've been doing various
different things and we all know that
well uh that the foundation well-being
is good night sleep so if I could share
just one thing to improve my night sleep
and wellbeing is taking the number one
mineral for that which also helps me
personally on so many levels that I
can't even describe and as you just
mentioned Ian it is magnesium I am
taking magnesium and is breakthrough for
Bio optimizers the seven different forms
of magnesium in this supplement are
involved in over 300 enzymatic reactions
in the
body pretty much for every function in
your body that gets upgraded when you
take magnesium from the quality of your
sleep to the your brain function from
metabolism to stress levels and let's
face it even if your 2024 resolution is
not to focus on your health as it is
mine how are you really going to be able
to achieve all your goals without
quality sleep and stress management
support really so do yourself a favor in
make magnesium breakthrough part of your
daily regiment uh this year and go to
bioptimizers
docomo and enter promo code bright
insight to get 10% off any order again
that's bio optimizers
docomomo code bright Insight the links
and the for both of those are in the
description and the pin comments thank
you very much for letting me read that
off now let's get back to DM love before
you tell me DMT can I say something
about magnesium pleasee yeah the center
of every chlorophyll molecule is a
magnesium atom uh it's it's fascinating
dude it's just like right at the center
and chlorophyll is like the base of
plant life it's like the chem it's
magnesium dude the way magnesium
interacts with got light I don't know
exactly but it's the center of
chlorophyll and it looks kind of like
the THC molecule the the chlorophyll
molecule right it's amazing in just over
on listening this was not planned you
didn't know I was going to mention
magnesium this was these these reads
that you know that I was to do on this
thing and so the fact that you just
mentioned magnesium right before I read
it it's like this is a real life
testimonial so again to anyone listening
this supports me and as you can hear
from me and it actually works I've tried
it it does work I think when you have
magnesium just magnesium powder and you
get it wet it explodes like people throw
magnesium why don't like like that kind
of potential energy in that chemical is
fascinating that's what we need in our
body that's what I'm talking about give
me that mag calcium mag I hear Cal cow
mags really calcium goes really well
with magnesium apparently I don't know
I'm not a doctor but I hear hey bro you
got that good mag you got those cow mags
B hey yo text me if you want that good
mag M you know what I'm saying text M
okay tell me this DMT thing man you saw
pyramid all right so this is on God this
is the truth this was in
2018 I was living alone in Boise Idaho I
had just got divorced not long before I
was going down this deep Spiritual
Awakening and I had just you know was
getting into my YouTube channel it was
starting to take off and I was just
looking for answers what I want to do
was an iasa Journey but I'm like I can't
travel at this time and and and so I'm
like well let me try to make some DMT I
went on eBay and bought the um the the
root in the bark the the Mimosa um and
what the other one called doesn't matter
um and then I looked on YouTube and was
able to find a video of someone making
it so I could learn how to do it because
I was reading instructions online I
couldn't figure it out I'm not certain
directions I'm like okay but this isn't
making sense but when you I see
something I'm like oh I can do it so I
made it and I don't know if the fact
that me making it and using my own hands
with it made a difference but what I saw
let me describe exactly what I saw and I
actually recorded myself like I set up a
camera on a tripod and because people
say that it will the memories of it will
disappear like a dream and that as soon
as you come out of it after just a few
minutes just say what you s what you saw
happen and you go back and reference it
later and made it easier to remember so
the first thing I saw first thing I saw
I I I saw the vibration and then I heard
the Ping and a pop and then I saw to my
left it was three two or three blobs
that had fa there were blob faces they
had eyes a weird mouth and they were I
don't know how to describe it then a
blob and it was giving me a weird look
and they look sad and they just looking
at me and I didn't get a good vibe about
them and then I look up and I started
seeing geometric patterns and I'm
looking at my closet in front of the bed
a slide open closet
a white closet but it's like the
blackground the background is black and
it's like people have described I
believe it was Terence McKenna saying
that it's like the something the dazzl
darkness or something I'm I'm not not
getting that right but now I know what
he meant but then I saw this feminine
being with a big head kind of elongated
if I'm being honest but it wasn't
elongated like I've seen in other
ancient text but um big old eyes not but
I didn't get alien Vibe but and it
didn't have hair but I just got a vibe
that it was a that it was a woman
feminine in nature and what I saw is she
was there was all of a sudden coming out
of her chest it was a pyramid here to
like here it was just aoop Boop trying
to find the camera here and it was just
sparkly colors of all the colors that
you can imagine like of the rainbow and
everything else and she was coming out
of the rainbow was her hands going like
this like Palms up like my
interpretation was like I'm showing you
this like hey Jimmy look look and that's
it this whole thing lasted three minutes
because I timed it because I had it
recording and I know people thinking
right now they're going to think oh well
Jimmy's into the pyramids that's why he
saw it I'm like guys I was depressed at
the time I was
literally and not I make videos on
Ancient stuff but I think about a lot of
different things I'm an inquisitive guy
and I my mind is all over the place
ancient history was not on my mind at
that period of time what was on my mind
at that period of time time was answers
and what's so wild just to finish this
story is that fast forward over two
years later I'm on the Giza Plateau with
a gentleman named YF aan who does tours
there he's the son of the late Akim
Abdel aan who was in The Pyramid code
and he is he teaches Kem about the
chians who are said to predate the
Egyptians it's w he's a wisdom teacher
teacher and what his father told him
because I asked him like what do you
think the pyramids were and what he said
is that his father said the pyramids are
us and I instantaneously without
thinking about the DMT trip thought of
the DMT trip I'm like when this feminine
being was showing me a pyramid coming
out of her body and he said that it's us
and I don't know what he meant by that
Ian I I don't know the man has passed
away what does he mean by the pyramids
or us I don't I don't know is it a code
what is it um but so this is like these
bizarre synchronicities and people
listening can can think whatever they
want I'm just sharing exactly what I saw
and how I perceive it I don't know what
it all means but I also felt inclined to
share it with other people I'm like what
what do you make of that I I I have two
two Paths of I want to go down but the
first one is what is chatology and but I
want to hold that one for after I asked
you about the frequency you said there
was a pop and then you heard a tone or
some sort of tone do you know what
frequency it was because I'm getting
into the R I just got a rif machine and
I'm if you don't have one you should get
one uh okay it's where you you you plug
in your phone you pick a frequency and
it runs it through like a I don't know
if it's a some sort of generator or
thing that like then converts the the
noise into then it runs it into this
copper coil that's like wrapped in this
with like 12 points this like 12 pointed
star and then the copper just vibrates
at that frequency and you can feel it
you can even hear it some of those
frequencies you hear it like I could
find it because I have this app on my
phone um you can get a tone app and it
can make it's all the frequencies from
low to toing like really annoying to to
so high that you can't even hear it but
your dog will it's really fun to play
with um it's also fun to do oh my God I
shouldn't even tell this story back when
I I learned it from a buddy that was in
my in the military years ago I was in
the military over 10 years ago and if
you go into like a latrine a bathroom
when there was like dozens of other
people in there you're sitting on the
toilet you press the Ping and like
people will freak because you can't tell
the direction it's coming from it's a
prank but anyway so in it I can assure
you that one of the frequencies in there
would be what I heard it was super high
pitched it I would know it if I heard it
and maybe I have to do this again um but
yeah I I guess with that device that you
have there would be a way of
establishing it it's just super high
pitched and it's loud and you can hear
it it's not it's not ttis I experienced
ttis years ago it since went away but I
know the sound of ttis and this was not
it it literally your hearing is picking
up on something it's not like a thought
sound it is one of the most bizarre
experiences I've ever had and what's
even more bizarre about it to me is that
Terrence McKenna had explained this he's
somebody who' done lots of psychedelics
and described the DMT trip and so what's
bizarre is that the way so many other
people have described this trip is
exactly how I experienced it which is so
weird I love frequencies in general if
it's if you're done sensory deprivation
when you have like no sound you can hear
tone like there's like a tone that's
constant that like we get the sensitized
to yeah have you done sep uh uh sensory
deprivation tanks saltwater flow tanks
no I would love to okay Ian is there a
place somewhere in town where you live I
will I will literally gift you a guest
pass to go try it so when back when I
was in Boise I was really headed down
the spiritual path and it was Joe Rogan
that convinced me to go try sensory
deprivation tanks and you hear it when
you're in there you're right like the
sound of in be mind is totally dark
there is no sound there's no feeling
you're in body temperature water you're
just floating it's like being in outer
space but there is that that low it's
like that pcking sound it's weird um but
you of all people need to try this
because I had got some of the most
profound ideas like it Al it helped me
my career I got ideas like I got ideas
for videos just laying in there for an
hour and if you do an hour and a half or
especially if you do an edible while
you're in there it is like honestly a a
profound experience that will benefit
you one it res it it's scientifically
proven to reset the central nervous
system so you come out of it feeling
really really really good um but on top
of it I am an add person if there's such
a thing as ADD um but I'm a fidgety
person my mind wanders 100 miles a
minute I'm all over the place I'm you
know one minute I'm interested in this
then an hour later I'm looking at this
but in there
you are forced to have nothing but your
thoughts and if you sitting there long
enough um you will have profound
experiences and by the way one last
thing before I hear your thoughts on
this is it because all the salt has
magnesium and absorbs into your body so
it it's it's physically beneficial for
you you have to do this you have to and
I'm dying to know what your thoughts on
it are I I was told by Corin nemic who
is a Freemason that that's what the
pyramids were they would go into the
into these sarcophagy filled with salt
water and they would cover themselves
and then blast off into these um where
you send your Consciousness Across the
Universe what is this called uh Cosmic
dancing I'm not sure there's a term for
it where recycle your your vision yeah
yeah um tele there's a there's a
specific word for it where you uh
someone leave a comment help us out yeah
you guys know what I'm talking about and
apparently that's what they were was
like these these sensory deprivation
generators they yeah it was like remote
viewing um I got a comment someone said
remote viewing there's another term for
it too the remote viewing is I think
what the CIA calls it for
sure um but like they would these
Stargates that they would the Native
Americans would stand in these circles
and it would let them tell yeah astro
Projection there astro Projection
Chambers interesting view commenter on
Rumble thank you very very much Tina
Rockwell toy dzing a bunch of other
people actually I can't even name all oh
wow tons Casper thank you no name
dancing yo yeah they know people know
and um so the the tips of the pyramid
were Captain gold maybe as a super
conductor for the Consciousness I really
don't know but that thing when that
thing would start vibrating man I bet
the because I'm all into this healing
vibration right now that's I told you
about the rif machine it comes from this
guy Royal rif if you haven't studied him
he's a guy you got to go down the rabbit
hole on Royal rif scientists in like the
20s or something or in the 30s 1930s and
he worked with like different
frequencies healing different ailments
killing different viruses destroying
certain
bacterium okay so this is I got the rif
machine it's like his great-grandson
cousin or something Matt rif is the guy
who's a contact who sent me a rif
machine how big is the machine is it
handheld is it like a computer is it the
one he sent me is about as big as my
phone um and then there's a wire that
goes to a piece of copper it's called um
the the the copper spoony it's 420 bucks
and it fits in a little zip bag and then
the big machine which I just bought is
like 5500 but it's like got these
gigantic copper coils and I'm like you
know what I got the spoony I used it for
like three nights it was vibrating at
432 Hertz I it was healing me the thing
about frequency is it only heals you if
you let it heal you like if you're tense
it doesn't really help it almost hurts
but if you open up you can feel like
everything clear like it it op it it it
it accelerates your momentum for good or
E for good or bad it feels like and
after a few nights oh after a few nights
I was like I got to get the big one yeah
I got to get the big one so it's in
route it's waiting for me at home when
I'm when I'm in town here in the next
week or so will you will you have it
there so we can kind of show me yes
maybe we could even play it on the show
we'll have it vibrating while we're
doing the show and here's what I want to
do you said one the the one that's
expensive you said it's real big big
yeah okay so I was gonna say I was like
if there was a way to bring that to
Egypt because here's what I want to do
it is yeah it's it's not that big it's
like small enough to fit in the backpack
it looks like
oh that's perfect dude we need to go to
the Great Pyramid of Giza together and
then you're going to lay in the Box YF
aan is gonna come up and do the oh
inside the box and you're gonna feel the
vibration off the granite I felt it
myself I've never experienced anything
like this in my life anyone in the
comments who's ever been to Egypt and
lay to one of the sarcophaguses and had
somebody sarcophagy and had people do
the AL in it leave a comment it is
Indescribable it's like nothing I've
ever experienced and I want you to lay
in it we're going to use the rif machine
you'll hold on to the rif machine while
you're in the sarcophagus in the Great
Pyramid of Giza will do the oh you'll
feel the vibration and we'll see what
the rif machine says yeah you don't even
need to touch it it's just these
vibrating coils that harmonize the room
I I've heard that this this this
Egyptian thing is an activation tour
they do like they call it activation and
I didn't understand that until now with
this frequency heightening it's so let
me let I told this story before I I told
you but let me tell the audience real
quick so like a lot like you were
describing the pyramids being a way of
like healing or teleporting or as
projecting and people like I do believe
that the pyramid Great Pyramid of G is a
operate in a frequency of some kind I
don't know if it restored our DNA I
don't know if it was for
telecommunication I don't know what it
was it may have been for generating
power I don't know I think all things
are possible I know that I don't know
but I know that that thing was not built
to be a tomb and you'll know it when you
go in there the design of layout you'll
be like this makes no sense but I'm
gonna tell this story because I think
it's important so you're familiar with
George St Pierre right GSP the famed
fighter yeah since retired he's
considered the goat the greatest of all
time um by many many people like if you
look at his actual record and his
achievements what he did it's arguably
like literally the greatest of all time
as bus described by many others so I had
the privilege of going with him to Egypt
in September I went to Balck with him
and he laid in the sarcophagus the box
in the Great Pyramid Yousef did the m
and what he said he came out of this
thing after being it for a minute and
his eyes were wide open and he said he's
like I'm coming out of retirements I'm
GNA win another world title now let me
just say he had he was going to come
back and do a grappling match no no
striking but just like you know to
compete he wasn't talking about that he
was talking about coming out of
retirement a winning world title now he
told me because I asked him a few hours
later I said hey what's up with that he
said no I'm not going to do it Jimmy I'm
not going to do that uh he doesn't want
to get in the head anym he's not doing
it but what I'm trying to describe here
the point the the moral of the story so
to speak is that he was in the
sarcophagus vibrating and the very first
thought out of his mind when he came out
of that is I'm gonna go back and be my
best self again and I'm G to do what I
was great at and I'm going to achieve
greatness again that's what essentially
he was communicating and I'm like I
don't it was just I felt like I
witnessed something very special
happened in that moment because that's
the first thing that went through his
head his eyes were wide open this UFC
champion and I'm like you know and so
I'm like hearing someone like that with
like it's very rare I was so blessed to
be around him he such a nice sweetheart
guy anyone in the comments that's heard
of GSP he's just as nice in person as
you could imagine I travel with him for
for five days and I'm like oh my God
this guy is everything he thought he
would be in more what a generous nice
guy and but the fact that this is what
he said coming from Legend like him like
that's the first thing go through his
brain after laying in a box that
vibrated in the Great Pyramid I'm like
there that is a there's something to be
said for that yeah it sounds like
activation I guess it's a matter of
sustaining the activation i i i i that's
obviously a challenge too because if
when you once you leave the vibration
it's like well oh I can feel the things
is there electricity in that chamber
like can we plug in to the wall or uh
because the Big R the big machine needs
to be plugged in as far as I can tell
the little ones you can charge up and
carry them around with you there is
electric there is no Outlet there is
electricity running into it because they
have lights as well as an air
conditioning unit in there I
don't I could I don't know for sure I'd
have to go back and reference my videos
and my pictures to see like could you
plug in I'm under the impression no
because what I I just remember seeing
chords I'm like here I am in the great
Pam m gees and there's cords
you're running through it I'm like this
is silly uh plus they have a camera in
there too uh up top but um so if
possible how much electricity does this
run on can it run on I haven't tested
the big one yet um the little ones are
on a battery pack you charge them up you
get about 30 or 40 minutes of them so we
could use the little ones but the big
one maybe we could just bring a little
generator like a solar powered DC
generator ACDC generator and plug in
while we're in there I don't know I I'll
know more after after next Monday I'll
know more start using it yeah uh by next
Monday you mean two days from now or the
one after that I mean two days from now
because it is Saturday now okay good
good good good because I won't see you
until it looks like next later next week
yeah we're going to vibrate at 432 Hertz
yeah the Harmon I've been studying the
the harmonic oscillations there's like
nine of them I think it's like one oh I
don't want to miscalculate them but they
they go up incrementally 432 is one of
them I think 520 is another one five but
anyway you can look them up online and
the the the 432 and the one right above
that are like really good they feel
really good nice nice dude hey by the
way quick shout out to rumble they got
us on the front page here my friend we
got a good amount of people I love that
dude what good people at Rumble Chris
pavlovski is an amazing human this this
this website is such a blessing dude I
people like that are listening on
YouTube that like why are you want me to
go to rumble like there are things that
have happened behind the scenes
involving censorship that I haven't
shared with everybody because I'm trying
to be a
professional but they are a free speech
platform and I've had the pleasure of
meeting him in person Chris pavloski the
CEO and I'm like these people are for
real they're they're they're wonderful
people the whole team um and people need
to realize that like we're living in
dangerous times there can't if you say
something that's too truthful they go
like this they cut you off your channel
they get rid of it it's happening I saw
you I saw you talking to Roseanne about
that when you were on her show what if a
few days I didn't watch the FL but you
were like there's a there's a joke about
the the truth is like poetry and
everybody hates poetry
right anyone listening um Roseanne Bar
legendary queen of Comedy she has a
podcast on YouTube and Rumble I was just
on with her it just got uploaded a
couple days ago go check it out I put a
link for it in my community Tab and I
blast it on social media but if anyone
listening to this didn't know about this
go to Roseanne Bar podcast on YouTube or
Rumble and it's the latest upload and
honestly not only did I feel like her uh
and her son Chris pentland and rosan
myself had great chemistry but the
comments are kind of validating it like
it's it's getting a really good
reception which I'm so thrilled about
because I really really admire her she's
a truth speaker she's not just a funny
comedian but she's someone who's really
stepped it up in the last number of
years to speak what she believes to be
the truth and that's something that I
respect in anybody and not to mention I
agree with her almost everything and um
and so I just recommend hey you go check
that out but uh yeah yeah also her son
Jake like I think might have said Chris
thinking of Chris pavloski but Jake
Chris pent excuse me Jake pentland did I
say Chris Jake P it was quick dude he's
awesome I want to go vibrate with those
guys dude him and I really hit it off so
like during the podcast when you're in
town here uh for the for the Turning
Point uh you know a few weeks ago Dude
him and I really hit it off like we're
like real life friends now like the
three of us need a the three of us
should do a podcast together yeah dude
that'd be awesome because he's
great he reminds me of my friends from
high school yeah he's hilarious he keeps
it real and not to mention he's somebody
that has changed his like he he talks
about he I was a Democrat All This and
like he's come like a 180 and he's just
like full-blown consp he went from like
not believing conspiracies to like full
down the rabbit hole he had a full
Awakening so what do you do with
meditation
personally I I brother I don't because
I'm too add so that's so let me tell you
this when I was doing the uh sensory
sensory deprivation tanks in Boise I did
it because I was trying to get into
meditation and I really struggled it's
hard to go 10 15 minutes with it but so
what I did was I bought a um a monthly
pass that allowed me to do one float
tank a week and so I started doing I
went once a week for like a while and
that was my form of meditation and I
would do it I started off in an hour and
then I learned that an hour and a half
is The Sweet Spot and there's so many
benefits it resets your central nervous
system like as I mentioned earlier the
Magnesium intake take but like when
you're shoved in there long enough and
it's dark and it's quiet and you have
nothing but your thoughts you kind of go
into this trance and that was the most
purest form of meditation I've ever had
in my life happened in there because I
was forced to brother it is so hard for
me to just go lay down in the middle of
the day and try to focus and meditate it
is I wish I had the mental strength to
do it but I'm like I just it's really
hard and I know there's thousands of
people listening right now in the
comments that like know exactly I mean
it's like I get things out of meditation
but it's so damn hard for me to do it
which is why it's so funny we're talking
about this I recently started exploring
to try to find a new saltwater sensory
uh deprivation tank place here where I
live to go sign back up again because
I'm like there was a piece of my life
there that was very enhanced when I was
doing that that I'm now starting to see
that I need to revisit um because it was
able I was the most productive when I
was doing that making videos and
such it's it's interesting you said 90
minutes because that's the RM cycle uh
from what I've read when your brain is
in sleep mode every 90 minutes you'll go
through a cycle of of oh some sort of
cycle and so if you want to take a nap
make sure it's in some increment of 90
minutes so like an hour and a half three
hours four and a half hours six hours
and you'll purportedly get the best rest
out of it because you're you're not
breaking a cycle what if that had
something to do with that 90minut
that's interesting um Ian I'm telling
you right
now I I will buy you your first because
it's not cheap it's like six the price
is very $60 a session it's like it's not
cheap if you buy in bul if you get a
month like you get like a deal but if
nothing else you should at least go a
few times the first time's a little
awkward and you will be out of your
comfort zone because you're essentially
lying naked in a in a huge bathtub with
a th000 pounds of salt that's closed and
and so you're out of your element and
it's kind of awkward so the first time a
lot of what I because I did a lot of
research on it before I did it because
it was really out of my comfort zone and
what I learned is that everyone that's
successfully went down that path has
said if you're going to do it at all buy
three passes go three times don't judge
it the first time go two times and then
if you're before you say you're not
going to do it again just do it one more
time and I know because I got a few
other close friends to start doing this
as well and they all said the same thing
like the first time they were they knew
they liked it but they're like should I
bother again and then after you do it a
few times you're like you understand
you're like oh now that I'm fully at
ease in mind you're you'll
physiologically kind of adapt in the
environment and get the true benefits
now that being said if I could afford my
own tank these things are like for a
brand new one they're like $30,000 you
could buy one used for a lot less but
I'm like I can't I can't I want to buy
that someday I know Joe Rogan is all
about that he has that but I'm like I
would do it a lot more if I could do it
in my freaking spare bedroom right like
I don't want to have to drive someplace
and do the whole charade of getting
naked and laying in some tank you know
it's like a Yeah Tim looked at buying he
looked at buying one but I was doing
some research and you need a room where
it's not going to corrode where like the
vapor is not going to corrode stuff in
the room so like tile instead of like
there can't be like open wiring or
drywall or whatever right I looked at
put it outside and that like not really
a good idea so we kind of juston to keep
it at temperature yeah a lot of upkeep
has do you know if if Tim has tried
it
um I think he has not I don't know for
sure but I think he's not he I imagine
he would have mentioned it but I don't
know for sure I think he's not tried it
yet follow up
dude yeah go ahead I'm gonna do it next
week I mean this is like what I what I
kind of want to do is get a massage in
the day and then go get a sensory
deprivation like an hour later or
something like that you don't need the
massage and then no let me just say the
sensory deprivation tank is a massage
like so what's so bizarre about this you
you will experience something that you
have truly never experienced in your
life for a few reasons one you're going
to be in an environment where you will
hear nothing you will see nothing and
you will feel nothing and it's almost
like you're floating in space because
they keep it at body temperature and
when you come out of it because like
you're laying horizontally floating
gravity will do its magic and it almost
feels like you got a massage like it's
like your spinal cord is like naturally
stretched out like you know it's like
you lay in bed you're taller technically
in the morning by like a like a fraction
of an inch or
something I mean get the massage first
but I'm like the first time you go go in
there pure and natural without the
massage because I'm telling you you come
out of it feeling really good I hope
people are leaving comments my God like
I haven't looked at the comments in a
few minutes like people if you've used
used the sensory deprivation tank tell
Ian right now what your experience was
yeah I want to hear it I the first time
I go I'm going to just go pure and then
the next time I might bring the rif
machine and tune it to like 432 or some
some 230 Hertz apparently is a really
good one too it's like a anti- acidity
frequency I've heard I was doing that in
a stretching and the recovery of the
stretching was rapid like normally it's
sore for a little while after the
stretch like 30 or 40 seconds I need to
kind of let it rest but this was like I
don't know if was like doing something
to the acid and the muscle but it was
like way easier to recover really quick
shockingly quick it was we I would be
super curious to know because like
people like you and Tim inspire me
because like you guys are on your best
game like you guys are grinding you're
busy all the time you're working hard
and like I said when I was using the
sensory deprivation tank I was the most
productive I had ever been in my life
and I was coning you know firing out
videos weekly and you know and so I'm
trying to get back into that it's not
easy guys um but I'm like now I need to
see I need to make some adjustments to
do all the things that I once did to get
me back on my best game so with that
being said someone like you and Tim that
are are are are on your grind I'd be
super curious just for the sake of
posterity to know what you two what you
get out of it after using it a few times
and I almost would encourage Tim to look
into trying to find a way to get one you
know I know it's not easy and it's like
it's a pain in the ass you have to make
changes in the household like but it's
possible it's
possible yeah I think once you use it
too you know you'd be way more likely to
want to buy one I I really want I want
access to one other things that are
fantastic are sauna which it's not the
most it doesn't get me inspired like
vibration does uh but it it it heals
like like immense healing properties it
uh it's a it's a steam sa we have one at
the house and it's like you go three
days in a row in that thing you're just
dripp like you just like total detox
mode and cold plunge you ever do a cold
plunge I just recently got into it now
it's been I got sick and then it's been
a few weeks since I've done it and I was
just talking about doing it again so
I've done it uh several times and I
could not believe how good this was this
was the hardest thing in like I am one
of these people so I have the ginger
Jean I was born with strawberry blonde
hair and it is scientifically proven I
didn't know this till not long ago by
the way that the gingers are more
um uh are more was it heat and cold
bother bothers them more so for example
I was always the kid that took a half
hour to get in the pool like you know
step by step because it's like so much
so for me to to finally do the Cal
plunge was literally the hardest thing
I've ever done in my life or at least
top three I'm not kidding when I say
that it was hell to get into this thing
and then the benefits of it the dopamine
rush I got out of it I was like I felt
alive I felt so good yeah I hungered for
it literally in my gut in my stomach for
like the next day like 20 hours later I
like I was hungry for the cold literally
I felt in my stomach was like I want to
eat that temperature I want it like I
want food it was a im it was awesome
feeling awesome I've never in my life
felt that for anything other than food
before it was wild Indescribable like
how many so is this something you're
doing on a regular do you have a cold
plunge out there I did it once Luke's
got one at his house Luke row
I'm going to do it the next time I go I
haven't done it yet at his house he
always tells me to do it do you know
what temperature he had
it I don't I don't I think it was at 54
degrees or something okay there's
different temperatures I hear high 30s
low 40s I've started off doing mid-50s
and I got down to the 40s I still
haven't done one in the high 30s yet um
but um what I will say to people
listening so the scientific like to
people who want the the what's known
about it is that going into the coal
plune they say that the most ideal is
like 39 to 41 degrees but the
temperatures vary for different people
like for example I got the dopamine Rush
doing it at 54 degrees so like it's all
you know it's all good um and so
essentially that your brain it it sends
you to a fight or flight mode and when
you sit in there for three minutes the
this dopamine is released that is from
the same chemical or it's the same part
of the brain that's activated when
people do cocaine so but it's natural so
it like you feel high on life you feel
so good you feel energetic you feel
focused and someone like me that's like
add and all over the place I'm like oh
my God I got out of there and I was like
this is phenomenal and like I was
addicted um but I've been ghetto riging
it so I don't have my old cold plunge
but the house that I'm rening has a
really awesome master bath that's like
70 or 80 gallons it's huge and so when
you go in it uh what I do is I fill it
with water and we have a chest freezer
and I have a bunch of liter and a half
bottles of Frozen water dozens of them
and I throw them in there uh for like a
half hour hour before I jump in and it
plummets the water another 20 30 degrees
and so it's ghetto but it works you know
you gota wait for them to refreeze again
but what I want to do is get a
sponsorship where they'll I'll I'll
Market the the C punch because I believe
in it so much and then they send me one
because I'm like should I buy one they
can be kind of pricey depending what you
get you know but that's what I really
want to do oh that'd be awesome there's
a a video of you doing it is so
entertaining I have a video on my
Instagram of me doing one the one Luke
took it Lukowski yeah if you take some
videos yeah that's a good idea dude yeah
is there a company in particular you
know of that does really good ones I I
think there's like one that does like
the best or something so there are some
that are super high-end I know so the
reason why I went down this path is
because I remember seeing people that
inspired me Joe Rogan Dana White George
St Pierre they all do it and so I know a
company ice barrel.com that George
sterre promotes and it's it's like a
thousand 750 bucks a thousand bucks
whatever it is which is because some of
these PE you know these go for four or
5,000 if you get a super super nice done
um but so like but you get one that's
more cost effective but no I cannot
recommend one because I just don't know
what I will say is that these people
like Joe Rogan Dana White George St
Pierre other people that are truly
living their best lives that are on
their grind they preach about it they
say they use it every day or virtually
every day and they start their day off
with it and it sets it sets their focus
through the roof calms them and to be
honest with you when I used it it made
me feel so this will sound silly but
I'll just share because it's the truth
it made me feel tough I'm like oh my God
I could withstand torture from this like
I felt like because it was so physically
difficult for me to get into that tub
and then having done it you feel like
you conquered something it's a I might
as well have hiked a mountain like it
really does something in your brain that
is so beneficial I hope people listening
will try this people that are listening
that were tempted I hope tomorrow they
they pull the trigger and do it I was
doing um uh Vim Hoff breathing while I
was in it which is that I don't dragon
breath but it's like
a
right just keep doing that it raises
your body temp and like people were like
oh they were kind of impressed by but
that's if you ever fall into cold really
cold just do that you'll like start to
Ste it was I know the William uh
willhoff that you're talking about I
didn't do it like that I did um I just
basically go I was just that's you just
breathe in and it just you know three in
the nose hopefully you it's easier to go
through the the the mouth but you're
supposed to do nose I think I'm not sure
or maybe maybe it is the the mouth I
don't know supp to be in through the
nose out through the mouth but I don't
know Breathe In Breathe Out deep and it
unbelievably makes a
difference I heard if uh you don't have
access to a cold plunge that just I
think Andrew huberman might have been
talking about it neuroscientist
brilliant dude it might have been Andrew
it might have been somebody else just a
bucket that you put your head in an ice
bucket uh just getting your head in the
in the cold or it might even be your
face but I think getting the head in
there gives you a lot of the benefits of
the cold plunge itself
apparently it's like a just a cheap you
anyone in the house can do it you get a
mixing bowl fill it with some ice water
sounds like hell yeah it sure does but
you overcome hell man you are Dante I
never read that book but did he make it
Out of Hell by the way or was the whole
I don't know how many layers he went
down my
high school or my
senior uh literature teacher in high
school made us read it I don't remember
much about it now but it is interesting
you bring that up yeah there's different
layers of it I don't remember I don't I
don't know if he made it I feel like he
did make it out I
don't who is his guy in that
book it may have died in there like
everyone else yeah yeah yeah um what's
next man
Atlantis well what are your other recent
what are your other recent um
discoveries because I haven't talked to
much about it in the last like three
months so the things that I'm working on
now so the most important thing that
I've worked on is what's coming up now
and it involves I well let
me I don't want to share too many
specifics because some people will copy
me um but it involves climate change and
histories cycles of catastrophe on Earth
that's my next video and I intend to
have that done before I come out I just
needs to be good because this is this is
one that I intend to make some waves on
and send out to some people and be like
hey look at this listen to what I'm
saying here and here's the data so it
needs to be good so if it's not good
enough by the time I'm flying out next
week then I'll I know not to rush things
but there's that so I'll hold off in the
key details just because like it is
something that other people may want to
go down but after that I want to do pul
shifts and ball Beck pul shifts to talk
about give a
comprehensive report so to speak or
presentation I should say on poll shifts
here's the evidence here's what we know
here's what's I think here's what's
conspiratorial and just lay it out so
all can comprehend um and then I want to
talk about the ball Beck stones and give
a comprehensive presentation to show
that hey here's what I consider to be
the best example of a lost ancient
civilization after that I want to share
some lost Maps I found of Antarctica so
these are all things I've been working
on um and a few other things behind the
scenes um all of course we visit the
wrist shot in Atlantis I'll go there at
some point I told you before I was
working on a documentary deal with that
it's not looking promising at this point
um for it to ever see the light of day
that's a whole other story uh I don't
really feel like getting into at the
moment because it's a little bit there's
just different things about it I
probably shouldn't share publicly but
we'll the pull shift stuff though like
how do people like U measure it do is
that measurable oops um oops hold on I
messed with a thing here um yes so well
it's in some ways measurable like it's
measurable from the standpoint that we
have scientific evidence that it's
happened several hundred times that
we're aware of over the last few million
years we know that we're like 200,000
years overdue um we are able to
establish this through so when volcanic
rock solidifies or when Pottery is
hardened solidifies wherever the
magnetic north was at that exact time is
exactly where the compass will continue
to show it's like a time machine so if
you go if you take a compass around
volcanic rock you'll that's old ancient
you'll see the compass move right in
front of it and it's showing you exactly
where magnetic or is it true north no
magnetic north was at that time where is
it true north either way you'll see the
compass move to where the poles were um
oh my God hold
on Tony heler I've been following
everybody followed Tony heler on Twitter
I just saw this this Super Chat would be
a very good person to have to talk about
climate change modern history the data
he might also have information about the
younger Dr boundary and cycles of change
thank you so much for this this comment
k um not to like get myself sidetracked
but like he's somebody I've been
studying and he is providing hard data
that proves exactly where like because
like they're saying like oh this is the
hottest summer on record this is the
hottest year on record the hottest month
he's showing that these these these data
points are fabricated and that it's not
true and and I I follow up I'm looking
at his data and I like Google I'm like
so this guy is like the number one
follow on this stuff some of my data
will include some of his I think but um
not to get sidetracked uh but I just saw
this popup just now and I'm like he was
somebody that was in the back of my mind
when I was just sharing what I was
working on so it's kind of interesting
to see this comment um any where was I
or you go ahead go ahead I would I'd
love to go hard on Tony heler and just
understand more about him but like I'm
thinking about when you're talking about
magnetic north like the pole shifts of
earth when they move is that because our
orientation towards the center of the
Galaxy is moving like these the wavy
arms of the Spiral are going up and down
as it goes down the the magnetic north
twists over or
so here's what I okay so first of all
they'll say it has to do with all what's
happening in the center of the earth
what I'm curious about is that like for
example the Earth is tilted at 23 and a
half
degrees that is a
mystery nobody knows why that is in fact
almost all the planets in the Solar
System
are tilted at different degrees some are
like totally like half over I think I
don't know if it's Neptune or Uranus
it's like 70 degrees wild so I'm like to
answer your question like I'm like I've
heard Elon Musk talk about in the past
how Galaxies have collided that would
have sent ours through a loop and so I'm
thinking that there's something why
wouldn't our solar system be influenced
by what the the Galaxy is doing so like
I think it all go hand in hand Maybe
maybe pull shifts are the result of what
happens with the Galaxy like people have
suggested that pull shift will happen
once our orientation in the cosmos of
this galaxy cross the um the galactic
plane the middle the um you know the uh
what do they call it the dark portion um
I'm I'm drawing just a blank in the
moment cool uh V
Horizon Middle the black the super
massive black hole Sagittarius A that's
not what I'm thinking of it's no the the
galactic Rift the Great Rift they call
it it's so when you look up like you a
dark night and there's not a lot of city
lights so you see the dark portion
through the middle the middle of the
Milky
Way so what's Wild is that that is like
some unknown cloud of whatever that's
allegedly blocking out stars behind it
and it's called the Great Rift and so
some people have specul speculated that
maybe there's gravitational forces I
might not be describing that right but
when you when our portion every 13,000
years or whatever crosses over is when
we cause us to flip I don't know if
that's true that's what some people
suggested oh but like it goes exactly
with what you're saying like that's what
some people have speculated so when the
poll shifted they literally flip North
becomes South South becomes North is
that is that how it works like a compass
will Point I've never heard of a compass
pointing South that's why I'm asking so
this is what's Wild there are two things
to be said on
this here's the mainstream scientific
consensus on this is that it's a
geomagnetic flip which means that our
compasses will flip that it means that
East will now be west and south will you
know or excuse me West will now East and
in North and South um but not that the
Earth flips over what I have described
the conspiratorial thing from the Adam
and Eve is that no it is literally a 90
degree flip not a 180 but a 90 degree
and it sits that way and on the sixth
day it sets back and on the seventh day
things start over new and that's what
some people say Well w that's
interesting the Bible talks about God
creating all this on the seventh day
rests and and and things settle um what
I will say is that these people in the
mainstream literally have no idea what
they're talking about when it comes to
geomagnetic pole shifts because they'll
say that um it should not be cataclysmic
it might cause some um telecommunication
and satellite communication systems and
electrical grid uh uh fallout on Earth
which to me is like okay well that is
cataclysmic if our lights go out if our
satellites go down if the entire
internet goes down our way of life has
ceased in that moment but what's
interesting is that they say that the
geomagnetic pull shift because happening
in the center of the earth that the iron
core essentially shifts and causes the
compasses to shift so if a certain
percentage of earthquakes originate in
the crust and a certain percentage
originate in the mantle the liquid
portion of the mantle is floating it's
it's literally we're floating on top of
it so if something causes that to change
why would that not cause earthquakes and
volcanic eruptions on the surface it
seems very logical to me that that makes
sense I can't prove it but if you read
any Main stream article about the jum
pole shifts they all I swear they all
conclude with the same way that they did
with Co by saying that oh there's no
evidence there this you know scientific
scientific they all say that it will not
cause cat you know it will not cause any
issues on Earth and I'm like why do they
all keep saying this you don't even know
that how could you possibly have known
we haven't witnessed one so anyway get
me off my soap box I'm gonna be talking
about that in future videos there's
there's theories that the pole shift
influences volcanic activ
or earthquake seismic activity no so
they all say that it doesn't Ian this is
what's so wild these all these articles
go out of their way to say that it won't
happen and I'm
like one it is impossible for you to
know that because we've never witnessed
one two that
defies common sense if our compasses are
based on the iron molten iron core as
assuming that that's true and I don't
doubt it I'm just saying that that
that's what the scientists say Okay if
that shifts so much so that it causes
our compases to shift and if earthquakes
some percentage of the earthquakes
originate in the mantle that is
literally floating and doing what it's
doing if there's a massive shift inside
the earth why would that not cause at
least some
disruption at the
surface yeah disturbance at the very
least I think
earth when I'm talking about it I'm like
I don't want there to be earthquakes or
volcanic eruptions so maybe that's why
they're saying it won't happen Don't
Panic everyone just keep going about
your business and pumping the economy
full of what high fructose corn syrup
whatever the going on yeah yeah
eat it your TV dinner make sure you
microwave your plastic definitely
microwave plastic it's good it's fine
that's when whenever his whenever they
say like yeah I order these Factor meals
and I do I have been microwaving them in
plastic it's just such a bad move like
go do it do it in glass in porcelain
just dump it out on a plate and cover it
do the whole thing it's been
scientifically proven to to to release
carcinogens and even ones that they say
are microwave
safe they come up with those figures
based on what these scientific
consensuses based on um parts per
million that are released every time you
heat for example people listening never
use teflon um non-stick pans even though
they're lovely um never use plast hard
plastic um utensils to stir your meals
um they say that they're
safe bro our cancer rates are skying
like through the roof they keep
increasing and it's like in my mind I
the most likely situation is because
it's what we're consuming and I believe
it's because we're releasing like they
already bro there's plastic in our blood
and it's it's more than just drinking
out of this plastic water bottle which I
virtually never do I do my live streams
because it's here it's ready to go and
that way I don't spill it knock it over
and I can seal it so it's not something
I do on a regular basis br you got to
take that stuff out of there it's
causing cancer dude I got this these
metal water bottles for the road and uh
they come with a built-in filter I was
so tired of it's a brda brda filter so
tired of drinking like sink water out of
random hotels in metropolitan areas with
all the Pharmaceuticals in the water
yeah my was yeah this doesn't get rid of
fluoride you need like a silver filter
for that did you hear that they that
they were trying to legislate silver
filters were like uh what did they do to
that company berky they they had bery in
some lawsuit because they're like your
silver water filter is now considered a
a certain thing that because it the way
it tweaks I don't why I even
bring that up I didn't have the full
story everyone listening needs to drink
spring water do you guys have spring
water delivered or or let me rephrase we
are we're very fortunate we have well
water we have well water at the house
that I live at and it's it's a double
filtration Osmosis System it is so it is
so pure it is like you gave me a glass
of water delicious I remember this I
don't know if as much as you want yes
yes so much water at that house 80
anyone listening 80% of of cities in the
United States put fluoride in the water
and it has already been proven through
various scientific studies that fluoride
reduces IQ this has been established in
school children it reduces IQ by at
least five points bro I don't know how
much Five Points is but I'm looking at
the dumbing down of our society and I'm
starting to think that fluoride is
taking its toll and I say this with love
I say with love but I I pay I pay to
have spring water delivered to my house
and it's worth it and a lot of people
don't want to pay you know $60 $80 a
month uh for water that sounds
ridiculous but dude this is your
brain you're breaking up I got a buddy
Jason pige he he sang the original
Pokemon theme song fcet can you hear me
now is this a little clearer you're
you're perfect just jut out then back in
awesome my buddy Jason Jason Paige will
go to the mountain and like get get the
spring water directly out of the
mountain spring he'll like drive up
there with a bunch of jugs and fill them
up and then back I think that IQ um that
that uh he's awesome I'll introduce you
to him someday it's fascinating dude
he's the guy he's saying the original
Pokemon theme song so his voice is well
known by by the Manar brilliant loving
human being Jason Pig yeah he's so great
but the the the fluoride thing you said
it reduces IQ by five points and I
imagine that's compounding like it's not
just like five and then it it's done
it's like over the course of a lifetime
with the average amount of fluoride
intake I mean Florine is the most
Electro I think it's electr negative
chemical in the Periodic Chart meaning
it's the chemical that's most likely to
strip an electron away from another atom
and cause free radical damage so it's
it's a very potent Florine is a very
potent chemical it's also a documented
it's classified as a
neurotoxin I don't know if it came from
Industrial Waste what they they're
repurposing Industrial Waste and they're
like aluminum wa Alum whatever that
means and they're like what do we do
with it just put it in the in the water
supply because it's good for people's
enamel yeah okay okay I have to say this
that's what they I I love going on
tangents about this forgive me I'm
having
fun that's why they put it in the water
according to them is that oh this
reduces tooth
decay okay then why shouldn't I just put
it in my mouth swish it like mouthwash
and spit it out why am I consuming it
through my body if that was true bro
everything we know about how this world
works that anything that's good for you
costs more money anything I mean and so
they're just doing it out of the
goodness of their heart to put in our in
our uh City water that makes absolutely
no sense and to your point about it
being like compounding the studies I'm
citing about reducing IQ by Five Points
was out of children I haven't seen a
study about adults so there's no doubt
in my mind that if you're drinking it
over the course of 60 to 80 years your
bra I mean why are Alzheimer's and
Dementia skyrocketing I'm I'm sure
there's a number of things about that
especially people living a sedentary
Life Style and watching TV all day
that's not good for the brain but bro
this is a literal neurotoxin you need to
why are we consuming it also compounding
in that the children of the people that
drank it their whole lives are now going
to be born with a lower IQ then they're
going to drink it so like I don't know
how long it's been being dumped into the
water supply 100 years 80 years not that
long it's after World War I so the
conspiracy is that Hitler is putting it
in the concentration camps to make the
um the everyone more docile I don't know
if that's true that could maybe that's
not true I don't I don't know I wouldn't
be surprised if it was the Nazis that
had figured out because they were doing
all kinds of technological things that
were Advanced at that time um what I
know is that like bro if there's
anything I understand about this world
is that if it was good for your teeth
they would bottle it they would
literally bottle fluoride and put it on
the it'd be right next to the toothpaste
like oh yeah you buy your toothpaste buy
your fluoride oh here it is oh yeah hey
honey I'm about to hold on one second
I'm gonna Garo my fluoride for a second
spit it out give me a second like like
like mouthwash the fact that they're not
bottling it the fact that they're just
throwing it in at the goodness of their
own hearts into the water supply for you
to consume and piss
out makes no sense but they here's what
they say let me just because I've
researched this they say well
come on we're putting such a small
amount parts per million that it's not
going to have any feasible effect on you
you're fine trust the science
bro it's so gross dude I I started
brushing without with toothpaste without
fluoride Toms like fluoride free but
I'll what I'll do is I'll have a
fluoride toothpaste that I'll use every
once in a while because it cauterizes
the enamel like if you ever get start to
get some Decay and you do the fluoride
on it gets hard like hardens it but it
bad for the endocrine system I think
it's probably good like once a week or
something like that like I do the same
thing I use non-fluoridated toothpaste
and then occasionally I use the
floridated stuff because I there's no
doubt in my mind that actually has some
benefit I just think that scrubbing into
your gums twice a day every day might
take its toll oh yeah it goes through
the skin it goes through the blood Skin
Barrier like do does it actually calcify
the panil gland because this is
something I've been told for the last 15
years so I don't know that's the
conspiracy I haven't seen so I used to
say this yeah calcifies the pineal gland
I wouldn't be surprised but I don't know
it I haven't seen like a specimen that
shows like look here's a prime example
of somebody we knew you know what I mean
so I'm like it's possible it's not true
but there's no doubt in my mind it's
having cognitive effects it is a proven
neurotoxin it's proven to reduce
IQ that's all I need to hear and plus I
just know it there's something about it
I'm like why they are here you really
want a conspiracy
who who's selling and who's buying the
fluoride where's that coming from and
who's making the money you ever drive
down like some like millionaire
neighborhood like some gated community
you're like okay that must be a plastic
surgeon that must be an orthodontist
that must be a lawyer but all these
other houses that are worth tens of
millions of dollars like what do these
people you ever wonder what these people
do for a living I want to know who the
people are that are selling fluoride
because something tells me they have a
big house when I found out who was
making high fructose corns syrup which
is considered a food in some places uh
it was Dow Chemical I'm like what the
so I like went into the Dow
Chemical website and I went down the
rabbit I looked in that website for
hours I was searching like how do I find
out how they make high fructose corn
syrup I was fascinated and it took me to
Dow and then I went down and it was like
well they have these tanks and then they
washed the tanks out between between
mixing and making this they'll
flush it and then they'll they'll wash
the tanks and I I don't want to
misrepresent it but I believe it was
arsic they would they would rinse the
resin out of the tanks with arsenic or
something some toxic chemical but they
didn't have to put the toxic chemical in
the ingredients of the high fructose
corn so because they were just cleaning
the tanks between production but like yo
that shit's going to get in the
production uh that's kind of gross but I
was just like so who's making the
fluoride I don't know if it's chemical
waste it's who's pumping it out it one
big uni party I don't I would love to
find out actually we just got a funny
comment from a guy Scott Bramley
drinking fluoride for your teeth is like
drinking sunscreen for your skin yes do
you even use sunscreen no um I
don't use it yeah I
I I just always had this intuitive
feeling it wasn't good for me and it
turned out to be right because it tons
of sunscreen is has carens in it I know
there's some natural stuff I just know
that like I my pasty white skin
should just get limited amounts of sun
here and there and like when I go to the
beach whatever like be in the Sun for a
little bit and then cover myself with a
towel or a shirt and then kind of just
oh also eat more green vegetables that
magnesium because I swear what it seems
to be is if you get a ton of sunlight
you're like oh I'm gonna burn if you
don't eat meat don't eat sugar don't eat
that stuff that has high acidity eat
green vegetable only you'll go Brown
your your skin will tan instead of burn
it's got to be that magnesium yeah it's
that you're you become the plant
um so you were talking about that Ginger
Jean are you more sensitive to Thermal
heat but more resistant to radiative
heat well I I burn easy but like I use a
hot sauna so like you're talking about
the steam sauna and I'm a huge advocate
for for saunas um I've only used seen
saas a few times but I I'm not a fan of
thermal uh infrared saas um I'm into
those are radiative yeah thermal thermal
is more is just like steam that's
thermal I love that convective heat yeah
yeah yeah real heat all natural is the
way to go um real quick I just want to
read off a super chat from thought on
fire 222 National Database for local
Springs find apr.org thank you for
sharing that I hope more people will see
that but to answer your question like
awesome yeah yeah I got to look into
that um but yeah like anything that that
that um stresses your body is good and
that's why I've taken a more holistic
approach in my life is like natural is
the way to go baby I'm going to go to
the I don't want to stress my bladder I
gotta go to the bathroom but I'm still
listening to you while you're explaining
right on you please go uh we'll wrap
this up in a little bit because I gotta
go really bad um and I'm Gonna Keep
freaking water because I'm pars because
I'm
talking real quick while we have a
little uh moment here are there any
super chats does anyone have any
pertinent questions because I'm I'm
literally toggling back and forth from
Rumble and YouTube uh to read comments
and they're flooding so I'm missing a
vast majority of them fresh prins no I
do not have to do that I just have to
pee oh these comments are great um
honestly what questions you guys have
for us because you know anything that
stands out yeah people don't Bro Science
hell yeah bro science is the way to go
um but I swear guys like if there is
something that oh my God these comments
I got to pretend I didn't see that one
um if there's any thing I know guys or
anything I'd recommend that say I really
recommend buying your water buying
spring it's it's something that took me
a little bit to do I've been doing it
for a couple years
now it's just one of those expenditures
that you don't feel like doing like why
do I want to spend you could be $40 $60
a month I'm supporting two people so
we're doing like $60 to 80 a month in
water but we fly through water we're
using it for everything um I recommend
having spring water delivered out of all
things in your life I just know in my
gut that is one expenditure that people
should be
doing what do you get them delivered in
what kind of
container five gallon plastic jugs why
do you have to ask that because the the
the the five G the the glass jugs are
like $30 a bottle and I can't afford it
where the plastic is like $8 a
bottle maybe graphine jugs will help in
the future like make because this
plastic crap is like the oilbased
economy is just uh it's convenient but
at what cost yeah um I had a question
for the Audi I'm just wondering how many
Psychonauts are in the audience right
now I know it's not like I don't I don't
expect an answer but like
I'm someone that like explores the
Psychedelic realm you don't even need
drugs to do it just get into that Spirit
conscious that Spirit realm and like
interact with the vibrations man the
manifestations of of sound or whatever
the hell these things are uh that's my
path in life at this point I I I I'm so
drawn every every part of me is being
pulled towards it like a triangle I'm
like at the base being pulled towards
the tip I feel it just being sucked
towards it and you've done um migro
doing yeah psilocybin on New Year's Eve
I took just a tiny bit of a mushroom
stem yeah it was so clear it was so
wonderful I danced uh I had great
memories beautiful dream it it was
really really powerful and I'm looking
at doing combo next which is this toad
Venom um you scrape it this Venom off
the back of a toad and the shaman will
apply it to you through burning it into
your skin and uh it's a big purging
mechanism uh this psychoactive as well
but it's a lot about The Purge and
that's kind of a lot of people do that
to prepare for the iasa journey I need I
need so I've I've only done um
psilocybin once and I did a hero dose um
and I have never micro doed and that's
something I'd really like to do I think
i' get a lot of benefits out of it and I
I just need a hookup I'm like I thought
about making it myself but I do just a
research and a lot of people fail it's
like real difficult to get it you got to
keep it just the right humidity and
temperature and all that and I'm like I
live in Arizona it's not legal out here
and of course I do not condone illegal
drug use but I would that's something I
would definitely like to at least
experience and see what kind of benefits
I get out of it because I I just sense
it's something that's on my list
that the micro do is so amazing being
able to control that dose so it doesn't
get weird and like it's l literally
manageable like you can just use it and
go about your business as normal and
it's just you just have better memory
better for better regeneration yeah you
went you went look harder they would
they wouldn't think that you're like on
something so I could like do a little
bit of
it if you if you do the dose properly
yeah dose I tried to micro do LSD and I
would get these little gel caps and cut
them into like quadrants and then I'd
cut them into e and even that would be
too much I'm like I don't know how to
micro do that's that thing that's you
need to like a chemist to make sure
you're getting it but the mushroom
itself like if you just take a little
clip of the tip of the mushroom and just
eat that you don't even know it doesn't
feel like you had any wow nice I gotta
look into that um let's see here what
else do you want to oh hold on we just
got a super chat from gooey love stew
wonder what the natural uh cycle process
that oil gas plays within the Earth's
core and I suspect it may be a bigger
natural process okay so this reminds me
you guys got to look into Tucker Carlson
just had a gentleman on named Dr Willie
soon from Malaysia he was at Harvard for
31 years he just left and he is speaking
out and he brought up the fact that uh
Titan Saturn's largest moon has an
abundance of gas on it and it's like
wait if fossil quote unquote fossil
fuels were supposed to come from plant
and animal life that died off forever
eons ago um why is it found in other
places do those places have dinosaurs
and mass vegetation or is it a natural
process and I have heard and I can't
remember where um but that there's other
some people have suggested that oil is
produced naturally in the earth and it's
reoccurring it's just going to keep
going so I I I can't speak to it but
that's all I've heard it carbon's only
the sixth atom it's not that big of an
atom so Fusion happening at the center
of these planetoids could easily be
pumping carbon out
yeah you know you're making helium No
Doubt with a little lithium and then be
what is it bear I don't know the I
should know that the next bouth isn't
barium I don't know the fourth and fifth
but yeah maybe that's what's happening
the cores are
fusing and that's why they want to keep
oil prices so high because they don't
want people to know it's naturally
reoccurring because like if you tell
people it's going to run out keeps a
value on it but if it's just never
ending my theory now is is we go to
hydrogen based fuel economy it I might I
don't know if I've told you this at re
University I think I might have told you
this I talked with Jim T he's the
chemist that out of Rice University and
they're making a kilogram of hydrogen by
pulsing carbon trash with uh electricity
at 7,000 degrees with this flash Jewel
heating process and for like 0.1
milliseconds they'll just pulse this
this carbon and turn it into hydrogen
fuel and then for every kilogram of
hydrogen fuel they make they get $4.50
of graphine powder byproduct that you
can sell so you're actually profitable
making hydrogen then all this oil from
the oil industry they're like we don't
want to lose our our dominance is
selling our oil okay we'll turn your oil
into graphine by hitting it with flash
Jewel electricity so it's like I think
it's like we've solved the uh economic
uh crisis at least that's my
plan yeah I think that we're living in a
Great Awakening where like there's a lot
of things we thought were false are
going to come out to be true and I think
the next few years is going to be
incredibly eye openening for a lot of us
assuming that we're all alive after that
because things seem a little things seem
to be heading in an interesting
Direction um yeah I'm considering moving
to not moving to South America but
getting a place down there or like
spending literally I have considered
moving there just like well gez if I was
in Germany in 1932 I would have been
like yo I gotta get out of Germany but
the US isn't
like yeah it's not like that but I don't
know man it's like kind of we're going
to wait SE pattern this next year I
think a lot is going to be told in the
next year of like are we headed towards
good or are we headed towards
psych
like an abyss of Destruction and
death yeah I'm watching are you looking
I was watching you watching the comments
are we headed towards the abyss or are
we headed towards greatness and
proliferation I think I think we're
headed towards proliferation I'll read a
few comments here you're right you did
see me uh Dey 69 said check out uh David
du of Mario build reps they have some
great ideas and theories including
climate change expanding Earth P I have
heard of him I got to go back and look
at more of
that shaborn says I will hook up with
Jimmy for No Charge
great what else we got here anyone else
let's see
Jimmy um trying to filter through
here what questions does everybody have
I'm trying to look like it's so fun
these comments are
hilarious Jimmy try micro doing you will
Ben it will be gentle enough to help you
create without sending you off the rails
yeah 100% that is as high on my list as
it is and as soon as I get the
opportunity I'm G to take advantage 100%
THC too I've had some complaints
personally about THC like oh I don't
want it in my life but it's just the
dosage it overdosing that is no
good for me getting high is no good but
just the tiniest puff like I don't even
realize I've had it I'm just focused
like it's like dude I totally agree and
this is what I tell people like it's
it's all about the right strain and the
moderation like a lot of these strains
now you buy from the dispensaries will
be like 25 30% which is way too much I
tell people between 15 and 20% one
little puff do not hold it like some
bong hit
just butow right out and that's where I
get I mean it's just the best benefits
um being Stoned on the couch isn't
really my thing like if you can't even
remember like if you're watching
something interesting and you can't
remember what they said 10 seconds ago
it's kind of annoying and so I'm like I
think that they're overdosing people
people are overdosing themselves doing
they think they need to do multiple
Puffs and just keep doing it it's like
now you need to anyone that's like has a
huge tolerance to THC I'd say like you
need to do a detox and then go back into
it with you know a nice strain
researcher strain and just do small
moderation and that is the sweet spot
where you have the best benefits same
with with alcohol too dude like the way
they sell these bottles of beer that's
an overdose like you only need like a
seventh of a bottle of beer to get the
real alcohol value but I think people
that are using drugs for um the feeling
are are doing it wrong I've done it for
20 years so maybe not maybe maybe that's
a part of the journey is you learn by
doing but using it for the value like
the Psychedelic or the psychological
value instead of the feeling it's
similar with eating like if if you eat
for the healthiness of the food as
opposed to the flavor the taste you know
and you you can get that sugary out
and you like I'll eat the the the raw
Brussels spr out even though it tastes
like bitter I Know It's Just Pure
Healing like that's when you're using
food properly you can make food taste
good too obviously yeah man I'm all
about the vegetables like I sauté stuff
like I like you know I do some nice
olive oil and I put in garlic salt and
go and lime or or lemon and other things
you can do some amazing stuff um real
quick we got a lovely Super Chat from
Vincent Kane says Jimmy I can show you
how the pyramids are us I'm currently
writing a book about it how to contact
shoot me an email I'll try to see I miss
a lot of emails um but I am curious
about that and and by the way leave a
comment share what your thoughts here
with us too give us something to be
eager to to read um Jester King said
when the dust is settled of the next War
uh will we talk about the current world
leaders like ancients talked about uh
the zoos uh Odin Horas and so on uh what
would an ancient um deprivation tank be
like yeah looks like a freaking
sarcophagus I swear okay I I I don't
have the photos in front of me but I saw
a couple different sarcophagus uh at
different parts in Egypt where these
things are like 15t long and inside of
them on the top of the lid is literally
inscribed in it a being a person laying
flat out arms all the way extended feet
all the way extended just laying you
gotta see this I'm like this is what I'm
talking about like this is not where
someone laid in to die that's not what
that is dude that if you sleep like this
it opens up your diaphragm and you get
better digestion and then you get better
rest if you ever only have like 20
minutes to sleep fall asleep like that
and uh you'll you'll get because rest
and sleep are different you can get rest
while you're awake and you can sleep
without getting rest but right it's and
it seems to be tied to digestion as far
as I can
tell so if the float tanks are big
enough are they big enough were was the
float tank you use big enough to put
your arms out like that while you're um
I was in a large one like that no it was
enough to go to the side like this
though like what am I I'm trying to like
balance with the camera like this yeah
if I was like this like that probably
not I don't remember trying it but I
remember being like this totally
extended with my arms and my legs spread
like this and not touching
anything if you can
visualize still with me I was lagging
while you were doing that the whole time
your arms were just like good I got you
your arms were like that the whole time
CU I was lagging that was
awesome uh Um well hey man what else you
want to talk about I think we should
wrap this up here in a minute I
gotta okay yeah there we go let's rrap
it dude I'm getting prepped to go to
dinner here in a little bit this has
been absolutely awesome oh that's so
much better why would I do that the
whole time lovely no it was Sting the
mve well yeah dude Ian we have the best
conversations slowly I was turning into
a
ghost um real quick oh someone was
saying DMT with you man let's do an iasa
Journey yes okay that is as high on my
list as anything I want to do a
legitimate iasa journey I want to do at
least three nights maybe four a lot of
people recommend four at least once for
God's sakes and I want to have a hero
dose I'm I can handle my this
sounds so funny but like I did DMT alone
twice I can handle my I've had I've
well OD isn't the right word but I've
done two much Edibles at certain times I
know my exact number now so it won't
happen but there's been times where I've
done like way too much and was like
really you know the heart's pounding and
it's like most people would freak out
like I can handle my stuff I can be
drunk out of my mind and still not freak
out like I I am blessed I don't know if
this is really something to brag about
but I can handle my stuff like I I can
stay calm under the you know the
influence of whatever it may be and I
want to go do a hero dose of iasa and I
want to get some answers I want to get
in contact with the source and I want to
you know that's what I want to do um
someone said real quick just don't jump
into ice bath after working out will
have negative impact on muscle growth
that's good point they say to do it
beforehand which I can't even imagine
because my I'm so freezing I can't do
anything but I appreciate that super
chat I think we have one other one here
I want to read off real quick Jimmy
thanks for the great content this is
question the answers is his name did you
know it's a three-day at once on earth
look it up new vid uh check it out when
you have time I will check that out
that's a good comment I like learning
new stuff here sorry to interrupt you
Ian um but yeah I want us like where do
you think the best place would be to go
pull off an iow journey in short notice
because it's like do we have to go to
Peru like I want to do it locally if I
could but I know it's not on the up and
up um I know people that facilitate
things like like combo um that I think
can put us in touch in the right
direction so we talk about it offline
and maybe uh figure out a spot I think
I'd rather not go to South America if
possible as well yeah it's it's yeah
whatever's clever you know yeah um let's
talk about this we'll be in contact next
week person and um I think it would be
really really cool to document it I'm
not saying we have to film it happening
that might not be appropriate but at
least like have a testimony afterwards
where it's like you know me in front of
a camera you in front of a camera
afterwards like oh my God this is this
is what I experienced and then we do a
live stream to talk about it you know
once we've uh come back or whatever um
Bey cool I'm just about to do a I'm
about to do a cleanse before I got this
cleanse called the Zen Cleanse it's a
Zen CLE e a n z Zen Cleanse and it's
like a 7day cleanse that is full body
like liver um and kidney and then this
stuff called mucoid plaque you it
out dude it is the most mind-bending
when you see this stuff what comes out
of your colon which is your large
intestine this stuff coats on the walls
of the intestine over years and decades
and this is these long strands of bre
Brown goo that are like in your
intestines come out of you after seven
days of this cleanse and that's a big
part of the iasa journey is not having
that in you when you go into it
because if your body's in physical pain
and you're just desensitized to it
you'll that'll manifest as spiritual
pain and Agony and then people try to
puke out whatever they ate four days ago
but it's like so you you could do like
seven day of like of just a dietary
cleanse which is like low sodium no
sugar steamed vegetables basically
basically but also this full body
cleanse might be like a big big part of
having a pleasant journey so I'm gonna
be doing that the next couple weeks I'm
really excited nice um this is exactly
what I had heard I was in contact with
some people a couple years ago and
trying to set something up and never
went through but they did send me their
like like this list of like hey by the
way you're supposed to do a cleanse just
as you described like they said don't
consume this here's the things you
should be consuming that's it it's
interesting you say that yeah I'll send
you a link to the Zen Cleanse I've heard
this is like the best cleanse on Earth
that you can get uh it's not cheap I got
like the full total package it was like
$1300 or something for all five of the
packages but nice it's like a once in
a-lifetime kind of thing I don't think
it's something you do every every six
months or so it's like a seven day then
the other one's a 30-day cleanse and
then it's another one the other part of
it is another 30-day CLE and it kind of
cleanses your liver it'll cleanse your
colon it'll cleanse your skin it'll
cleanse your blood these different
cleanses for different purposes is nice
yeah I I'll show I'll send you a link
after we get offline hell yeah all right
man this was wonderful I'll uh let you
get to dinner with the crew um thank you
so much for your time we planned this on
short notice and and like we both said
like short notice is the it always gets
me the most excited about something is
it's like oh I like being SP uh
spontaneous and I just want to thank you
for your time Ian I can't wait to
connect with you next week in person
again and uh good things to come and I
think to anyone listening that enjoyed
this you're gonna be seeing more of us
together too that's what I'm talking
about dude peace and love brother right
on all right man till next
time much love everybody